today we're talking about kubernetes
recaptcha
and app sheet i'm stephanie wong and
welcome to this week in cloud
where we serve you the lowest latency
news from the safety of home
working with kubernetes often means
working with yaml
and custom resource definitions can
introduce even more complexity
that's why we wanted to let you know
about cloud code's expanded support for
kubernetes crds
cloud code supports ides and helps you
write run
and debug cloud native applications and
now also supports inline documentation
completions and linting for both popular
and
custom crds web traffic is at a
record high but for more than just
humans traffic from automated systems is
also on the rise
and while not all bots are malicious you
can keep your business
secure with recaptcha enterprise
enterprise introduces better security
risk analysis and abuse protection
without making your users select which
squares contain a stoplight
see how it works and keep your system
secure google workspace is all about
collaboration and staying productive
appsheet lets you take that one step
further by letting you build
no code custom apps or you can use apps
script to extend and modify with some
quick code
use either or both to do more and if
you're looking for how to get started
take a look at the solutions gallery for
some examples
finally thanks for sticking with us as
we brought you the lowest latency news
from the safety of home
it's been a fun challenge making our
content from our own homes
so we're giving the team a well-deserved
break this is the last episode of the
year
and this week in cloud will be back in
2021
if you want to read more about these
announcements check out the link in the
video description
and feel free to continue sharing your
thoughts and ideas by commenting or
tweeting us we'll see you in the cloud
you